[Music]
hi everyone
my name is danielle smalls perkins and
my name is doris scott
and we are the co-founders of my our
community
uh today during this lighting talk we're
gonna reflect a little bit on
my our community this past year and also
invite you to join some of the efforts
that we plan to carry out in the next
year
i'll first start with the hope uh for
myar uh so the hope from ir is to
promote the visibility and leadership
of our users from marginalized races
genders the lgbtq community and the
disabled community
through community-led efforts that
support professional development
right now we have slightly under 200
members and allies
within our community slack from
different countries backgrounds
experiences and all flavors of data
people data scientists
data analysts etc all these folks are
willing to share their unique
perspectives and their love of our
so some of the highlights from this past
year really
first of course was just getting the
group off the ground
and starting to see people roll in we
started right as the pandemic
hit hit the entire world and tried to
garner support
and momentum just as the u.s was going
through
a racial recognition excuse me a racial
a reckoning for racial justice so
to see the outpouring of support um
allison horst designed logo and graphics
for us
to see other members join and support
each other and lead new
initiatives that's just been truly
special
another huge highlight of this past year
where the webinar is
held by our community members darren
ramsen
led a webinar focused on some of the new
features in the recently updated deep
fire and then some of his favorite
functions
um associated with that library also
shell karuki provided a webinar focused
on g2 plot 2
and share some of her tips and tricks
when doing data visualization
we also had in our studio instructor
certification panel
led by greg wilson michelle karuki
yanina
bellini sabine in which they talked
about the process to become
an r-studio certified instructor
and have been hacked we've also been
having some study sessions
every month for those that are preparing
to take the exam to become
an r studio certified instructor so
those are
some of the top highlights i will also
pass it i'll now pass it to
doris to share a couple more reflections
i have a lot of reflections reflections
on how our first year went
as an organization but for the sake of
time
i will just share only one reflection
we originally created my r because we
wanted to create a space
in which people who did not see
themselves in the data science community
could come together
we hope that my r would extend past our
ability
to adequately support all of the
intersectional backgrounds that are in
the community
and indeed it has we are so grateful
for members of our community who provide
their unique perspectives
insights knowledge and skills thank you
so much for all that you bring to our
community
in 2021 we are working on several
endeavors
we don't want to give away our full
lineup so here's a preview of what's to
come
we are currently working on endeavors to
ensure that my our
webinars are accessible to my our
members with disabilities
along with the wider community of our
users with disabilities
and we are working on a tidy tuesday
event in which we will focus on best
practices to make our visualizations
more
accessible in addition we intend to have
more professional development workshops
such as resume workshops
and interview preparedness along with a
digital security webinar
for researchers sharing your work with
the public
so if you identify as an
underrepresented our user
then we invite you to join our community
as a member and if you'd like to support
the community but don't necessarily
identify as an underrepresented
our user then we would love to have you
join as an ally
in support of the members you can find
us on twitter and youtube
at meyer community and you can also
visit us
at www.my
thanks so much for listening to our talk
thank you